welcome to this video plates for lock
yeah I really have forgotten tis the
name here good job i cut yeah that's a
German I am let's see you there can we
get the Italian game yeah the sea 3d
three line the modern modern way to play
it I'm usually going for this setup here
that is quite solid delaying castling
for a moment preventing Bishop g5 and if
he goes age three I play g5 myself here
we go yeah it's a it's a tad crazy but
it is dangerous for for white so I'm
just just firing here okay but wow what
is this ok this is this this I have a
hard time to believe really isn't this
is good for me ok Queen f6 Queen f3
tings tings I mean that's definitely ok
for black only question is how good is
it
195 okay right that's definitely okay
yep 93 is a pretty pretty serious threat
h3 Hanks root G a check in the mix what
is this move Bishop d1 then I go 93 and
Tia has at least two against the given
exchange at least okay so let's do this
chicken shack King f1 Bishop h3 King age
to Bishop F to let simmer so he has to
go to f1 and then I'm taking age rivers
check but he can he can freak and go to
you can really flee but I have 93 king
of 193 as much stronger threatening
night f4 actually for Bishop e3 mate
this is much stronger and during the
night and the rook hangs of course up
but the main threat is not F for now and
this is just mate Bishop h3 mate almost
it yeah I came probably it's a bit
theoretical he will do some kind of move
and not just wait night f4 king in one
check
hmm I don't can also white resolve its
direct meet yeah i just saw it yeah here
chick and where's the mid check check I
came maybe that's not mate I'm
overlooking the maid manager I'd wins
all pieces it wins all pieces it's the
maid let's let's at seven look really
curious there I thought us jestine one
check check check ah this is I made this
is actually made checkmate very neat
okay it's nice okay so this is g5 movie
yeah I really think it's good i think
it's it's at least at least it leads to
very very sharp and interesting play and
um okay when this played this very
quickly g-form and i think d take c5 is
is just not good i guess to take on
reform TX takes a computer she says but
she just has black wins minus one point
something canned and over 93 immediately
was maybe even stronger it does win does
this is when he's just getting killed by
the active pieces was weds pieces are
totally uncoordinated okay that was nice
thanks for watching